with each slip of paper finland's next
government is being decided but it's
been too close to predict a winner
neither the social Democrats Northern
National Coalition party nor the Finn's
party held a significant lead in
pre-vote opinion polls coalitions are
the norm in Finland with the winning
party getting the first attempt at
forming a government I was on America is
very popular and she's done great most
of the films also think that she did an
amazing job with the coronavirus but
maybe we have to look at new
crisis that we have and some of us still
believe that she does very good job but
other people need want something new
with her Youth and Progressive politics
Santa Marin has been popular among young
moderates at home and abroad but living
costs are surging and Finland is
teetering into a recession
finishing up campaigning on Saturday
Marin acknowledged she's fighting for
her political survival
the situation is very tight we have
three parties that are I try to each
other any one of these three parties can
win tomorrow and of course we hope that
we will enter first and continue our
work that we have been doing for the
last four years Marin has presided over
finland's biggest geopolitical
transition in decades applying to join
nato in response to neighboring Russia's
invasion of Ukraine
but opponents were quick to jump on a
leaked video of her drinking and
partying with friends saying she wasn't
fit to govern Marin was cleared of
wrongdoing and arguably criticism of her
government's public spending has hit her
more for me I'm burdened by the
economics actually we take too much
depth I think I wish we would have a
welfare to stay still in 20 years time
but with the current expenditures and
debt taking I'm worried about how we can
afford the welfare state in the future
having become the world's youngest prime
minister at 34 it's possible Santa Marin
could be an ex-prime minister at 37.
Rory challenge Al Jazeera